[Music]
hi and welcome to breathing life into
the laws of physics i'm sarah walker and
i am a theoretical physicist by training
and i work in the field of astrobiology
and think a lot about the nature of life
and the original life in the universe
and i'm looking forward to discussing
these ideas with all of you today
um so the first part of this academy is
going to be focused on the universal
laws of life um so how do we actually
identify whether there are universal
principles that underlie all life in the
universe um and i wanted to start by
first explaining where the quote that is
sort of inspired
the title of this academy came from
so there's this very well-known book a
brief history of time by stephen hawking
where he mentions that even if there is
only one possible unified theory it is
just a set of rules and equations what
is it that breathes fire into the
equations and makes a universe for them
to describe
and i thought this quote was
particularly relevant to what new
physics might underlie life and help
explain life in the universe because
right now we're in a state in physics
where our theories not only do we need
to ask questions about where our
equations come from but we also need to
recognize that they don't explain us
and so in
my field that i was trained in
theoretical physics we've had a huge
amount of success about describing
reality at a really fundamental level in
terms of understanding the fundamental
forces of nature and realizing that
certain unifications of them
say for example the unification of
electricity and magnetism
um in the 1800s leading to
electromagnetism or more recently
the electro weak force and the standard
model particle physics have been really
successful at describing reality and we
think that we can keep going um to
what's called the theory of everything
um but of course as david krakauer the
president of santa fe institute points
out the theory of everything is a theory
of everything except those things that
theorize
um and so all of these sort of laws that
we've come up with are actually
inventions of biology and they don't
describe the biology
um
that
you know has actually come up with these
ideas
so i'm really interested in trying to
uncover whether there are deep
principles that also explain life
and some of the things that i'd like to
talk about with you all today
are that some of the things that life
does seem to challenge the laws of
physics as we understand them now and
might actually demand entirely new
principles and frameworks
now why do we think that this approach
might even work um
well i am as i mentioned uh trained in
theoretical physics so i have very much
have this bias
um that we have um
uh in my field um thinking that
mathematical principles uh should
applies pretty much to everything in the
universe and there should be a
fundamental understanding as possible um
and so albert einstein kind of puts this
idea very nicely that the general laws
on which the structure of theoretical
physics is based um claim to be valid
for any natural phenomena whatsoever and
it with them we should be able to
describe a theory of every natural
process
including life by pure deduction so i've
added the emphasis of life because
obviously that's missing from our
current descriptions of physics there's
no explanatory framework for what life
is
um
but i wanted to just emphasize that this
is very much the mindset of um
traditional approaches to physics so i'm
still maintaining this mindset that we
can find universal principles um whether
or not that's the case is still subject
of open debate so maybe life just
doesn't conform
to the kind of understanding of reality
that we get from physics
i am optimistic that it will um but it
might look quite different um but it's
still open possibility that it doesn't
um so one of the things i wanted to
start with saying where sort of the
dichotomy is between the way we've done
physics for the last 300 years or so and
what new principles might be necessary
to explain life um is uh to think about
sort of the difference between how we
think about dynamics um in life and what
life does as an evolutionary system um
and uh how we think about things in
physics and so this quote um now comes
from a nobel laureate frank wilczak who
was one of the pioneers that really led
to the success of the standard model of
particle physics
and he points out in one of his papers
that since newton's time we divide the
description of the world into dynamical
laws that paradoxically live outside of
time and initial conditions upon which
those laws act um and this was in part
what you know this observation is one of
the reasons that stephen hawking made
this point about what breathes fire into
these equations because they don't exist
inside the universe by our current
descriptions nor do the initial
conditions so these are sort of boundary
conditions we need to put on the
universe in order for our physics that
we have currently to work
now this gets really interesting when
you're talking about biology because the
newtonian paradigm
and the way that we kind of construct
all of the theories of physics that we
have to date are based on this idea that
we have an initial state and some fixed
law of motion so an example would be
say
newton's law of gravitation which
explains say planetary motion or some of
you may be familiar with the formula f
equals m a force equals mass times
acceleration right so the there's no um
change in the actual equation what
changes the variables in the equation so
the law itself is fixed and should apply
to any massive object um so these are
sort of the ideas that were first
established by newton and we still use
today
and
um part of the challenge here is that if
you want to explain how the world exists
as it exists now you have to use um one
rule um and sort of fine-tune the
initial state to explain the details and
features of the universe today so for
example if i want to explain how it is
that i'm here um at this festival
talking to all of you right now um
somehow the initial imprint of that
information had to be in the initial
state of the universe and then was
generated basically by the laws of
physics operating on that initial state
so this is kind of an extreme view but
this is one interpretation that you
could have um and many people do
by taking sort of the the standard um
laws of physics as we understand them
and then interpreting how they apply as
an explanatory framework
now the difference with biology that we
see is really we have sort of evolution
if you will in biology so you can start
from one
initial state or many initial states and
end up in many different final states
and what do i mean by that well
we have something that we call
sort of genetic heredity as an example
you have common ancestors for example
with maybe your cousins and your aunts
and uncles and things but you're all
very different even though you kind of
descended from similar
genetic lineage and so part of the idea
that people have talked a lot about is
that biology has
this kind of multiple histories or
possible histories and they're very
contingent on the particular environment
and particular features of the system
under study and the interaction between
those
and so we don't really seem to have this
kind of
application of a fixed law as being
applicable to biology
and this idea of course goes back quite
a long way to the invention of
evolutionary theory itself with charles
darwin so he has this beautiful quote
that will this planet has gone cycling
on according to the fixed law of gravity
so simple beginning endless forms most
beautiful and most wonderful have been
and are being evolved so of course the
newtonian paradigm allows you to take an
initial state like say the configuration
of
planets in our solar system and once you
understand the law of gravitation you
can run that system forward in time and
in principle you should be able to
predict
where all the planetary bodies will be
in the future
um now there's obviously challenges of
that in practice because once you start
having multiple interacting bodies
there's extra terms in the equations
that become more cumbersome to calculate
but in principle
sort of that's the foundation of how we
think about things in physics we take an
initial condition we have a physical law
and therefore we should be able to
predict how the system behaves
indefinitely
um you can contrast this with darwin's
endless forms most wonderful and so this
is kind of a more pictorial
visualization of what i was showing on
the previous slide with this idea of the
multiplicity of paths that biology takes
um so here we have this um last
universal common ancestor so i'll talk
about this a little bit more in the
second talk we have this morning
but the idea um here is that all life on
earth descended from what's called the
last universal common ancestor which was
really probably a population of cells on
early earth and since and that's sort of
the first um evidence that we have for
life on earth and the first knowledge
that we have of a sort of modern
machinery that we have in biochemistry
today
but since that time what we've seen is
that all of these amazing species that
basically cover the surface of our
planet from us to fungi
to bacteria
and even viruses and all of these things
have sort of descended from this common
ancestry
and it's not just that the biosphere has
created a lot of organismal diversity
but it's also created a lot of
innovation in other things so for
example um i am you know sitting here um
talking with you all on a computer and i
have a phone with me and a pen um and a
cup and all of these are technological
artifacts that are also the product of
the evolution of life
now a question is could you predict um
say if you knew the the last universal
common ancestor and all the conditions
on planet earth at that time could you
have predicted that four billion years
later or so or three and a half billion
years later uh a cup would would form
right so so this is sort of the question
so a lot of people that study evolution
um think that you couldn't pre-specify
what is going to evolve stuart kaufman
is very famous for saying this that
evolution is actually not pre-stable you
can't predict what's going to happen in
the future and so this is sort of one of
the major distinctions between when
we're talking about trying to explain
life and trying to understand it with
sort of the current paradigms that we
have in physics that they don't exactly
fit together
for this very reason
um and so just to kind of bring the
message home a little bit more it's
actually related to some very deep
paradoxes um at the foundations of
mathematics and computing um and
sort of the clearest place that we can
see this sort of dichotomy um it was
with this nice quote by nigel goldenfeld
and carl woes nigel goldenfeld as a
physicist carl woz um was a biologist
famous for discovering the three domains
of life are well archaea the third
domain um and um
what they they point out is that in
biology we encounter a situation where
the rules must be self-referential so
remember we said in physics the laws are
fixed now we're saying the rules are not
fixed
but they're actually self-referential
rules um what they mean by that is the
update rules change during the time
evolution of the system in a way that
they change as a function of the state
and the history of the system
um and so an example of that is just to
think about genomic information inside a
cell so we have genomes inside the cells
in our bodies not all of the information
in the genome is expressed at once um so
it can get read out into proteins which
proteins are expressed actually
determines the level of gene expression
and so there's this feedback loop where
the information in the genome specifies
what's happening but then that what's
happening specifies what's being
expressed as far as the information
or you can think about the fact that you
know you have thoughts your thoughts um
maybe if you if you believe your
thoughts influence your behavior um you
know there's a lot of subject open to
debate about that but that would also be
sort of a self-responsible dynamic where
there's some emergent property of the
system that then influences the dynamics
and what happens next
and in fact i mentioned that this is
related to the foundations of computing
because the self-referential nature is
actually foundational to
what turing discovered as far as
the insights around the halting problem
and kurt griddle's work about sort of
the incompleteness of mathematics and so
there's some very deep paradoxes
associated with self-reference and this
feature that a system might define its
own rules and then be able to act on
itself
and so this paradox is actually really
nicely captured by this um famous
illustration by m.c escher which was
trying to capture this idea of
self-reference if you have these two
hands and one is drawing the other
uh where do you actually say um
causation starts um and in physics it's
very simple where causation starts we
have sort of elementary particles and
then we have laws and everything else is
supposed to be derived from that but in
biology it seems that the actual
properties of the physical system itself
in part determine how the laws are going
to behave in the future and this is what
we mean by saying that biology has a
self-referential loop or so um sort of
is some kind of capacity to
change the rules
of the game it's playing um
and so um so this is sort of one of the
most important distinctions between um
physics and what might be necessary to
explain life
and in fact i i want to just point out
that the issue with sort of a fixed law
of motion and initial conditions is not
just problematic for trying to
apply the way that we've developed
physics historically to life but it's
also problematic in some areas of
fundamental physics itself so i had
pulled that quote um from frank wilcheck
earlier but he also points out in the
same paper where he's just talking about
standard physics so this is part high
energy particle physics
gravity you know sort of things that we
usually think about when we're thinking
about fundamental theories of reality
and where they're going in the next
hundred years
he points out the fundamental laws
should no longer admit arbitrary initial
conditions and will not take the form of
evolution equations because even in
fundamental physics these these things
are uh problematic and so one issue just
to highlight a specific one that i
already mentioned is this issue of
fine-tuning
because there are a lot of issues about
having to fine-tune sort of the initial
conditions to specify kind of what you
want to observe and the initial
conditions are not given for free
we have to put them in or we have to
derive them from another theory and so
these these kind of things become quite
challenging if you want sort of an
ultimate explanatory
framework to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you